my name is Rob joined by reviewer Callie
and this is GameSpot's video review of
days gone
[Music]
Kalli we're talking about days gone a
lot to talk about
yeah so I really want to be able to
expand on the review my review already
talked about a lot but there is really a
lot to cover in this game this game like
does really have its moments there's
there's exciting fights with zombies
like it's a zombie game with a
motorcycle there's gonna be exciting
bombastic things but the game doesn't
say anything interesting about its story
or its characters it you know it
abandons these narrative threads at
random the characters are
two-dimensional and at the very end
you're kind of wondering why you did any
of it at all it really lacks purpose
well let's start back there at the
exciting parts I guess which is the
combat and the freaker's yeah let's
probably start by explaining like the
the basic stories at Hope Church is you
play Deacon st. John
he's a former biker it's deacon and his
best buddy Boozer and they were in a
motorcycle club together and now they're
Drifters who go from survivor camp to
stir-fry over camp doing odd jobs for
money and trust which is the kind of
currency in that it unlocks upgrades for
you right I mean that's the gist the
freaker's are zombies and there's been
an outbreak and the story takes place
largely two years after that uh pre
Cap'n's um so naturally you're fighting
a lot of zombies so let's talk about
them because there's a lot of different
kinds of zombies
there are different types of zombies for
sure so the umbrella term in this game
is free kurz right in the first 20 hours
you're mostly gonna be fighting a type
of free food card called a swarmer which
is like those run-of-the-mill zombie
then you have bleachers which are albino
versions of swarmers but slightly
tougher and that's mostly what you're
fighting in the first 20 hours and then
during the second period you're
introduced to kind of kind of more
variations of zombies and in the third
you're really getting into hordes but
you see hordes throughout the game and
hordes or kinds of thing that's in the
background lurking and it's it's
stressful and you want to sneak by them
and so hordes are like weird like the
big deal it's the selling point of this
game that's the that's the big bad of
this game basically but you know you're
fighting bad people of course too and
there's human enemies but the hordes are
really it
you know you don't get a lot of action
with hordes beginnings you just aren't
equipped as far as combat goes you have
you know you're a terrible bike cuz
deacons bike got eluded at the beginning
of the game you have like the worst
parts of all time you get like a mile
per gallon so you have like a really
weak bike you have you know not very
good guns cuz you know the weapons you
have access to are of poor condition at
the beginning this game you can pick
weapons off dead bodies but you can't
they're not like yours to keep you just
have your limited like a like a dinky
pistol and then you have melee weapons
that you pick up around the map and the
melee weapons are like pretty much what
you're doing at the beginning you want
to make a lot of noise melee weapons are
you know anything from a pickaxe to a
piece of wood and you can do a lot with
a melee weapon so the melee is kind of
the folks at the beginning and that can
be kind of exciting it it feels good to
like hit a zombie with a machete and its
arm comes flying off as gross as that is
yeah that is a satisfying junk food
zombie experience that I think if you're
if you're gonna be fighting zombies they
gotta pull apart and in gross ways
[Music]
I'm gonna use your sons of [ __ ] are
there it's fairly obvious in the game is
that you know you start off with bare
minimum yeah tools to protect yourself
you're avoiding hordes but it's pretty
obvious that by the end you know you're
getting like a big LMG you're getting
all the gadgets and stuff to take on
these courts which again is the big
selling point it's yeah it's the fun
part of the game right but it builds up
so slowly you start out with just like
melee and then you you really got a wait
to do the Horde stuff when you finally
do the hard stuff
it is so exhilarating because you have
you know you've worked hard you've built
up your arsenal you've gotten crafting
you know ingredients and you have better
weapons and you you know it's a story
mission like the first time you are
properly formally taking on a horde as a
mandatory store mission and you are
fitted out and you go down in the areas
where hordes live are like elaborately
built with like trucks that have crashed
into each other or like trains that are
overturned and the buildings have like
stuff you can knock over get a zombie
off you and you know like a bookshelf or
whatever so that there's a lot to do in
them and you're just really fighting a
horde as a matter of like running
slowing them down by weaving in between
buildings cuz they're kind of all over
each other right they're like just
gnashing at you and then like lobbing a
grenade at them or lobbing a Molotov at
them and like the fire slowing the horde
down and like cool now I can run away
and take out my LMG and shoot at them
it's a it's all about like thinking fast
moving fast finding places where you can
regain your stamina which of course
drains when you sprint and just like
keeping the Horde off you whilst just
taking them out and these are hundreds
of zombies at once that's really
exciting
this is the thing in which we will get
to this it you have to go through a lot
of hours of not so great to get to that
moment and that's one of the problems so
the other not-so-great stuff you could
say and you did in your review is the
other activities in this open world yeah
so there are as you put repetitive
things that you end up doing like taking
out nests
ambush camps can you explain so in that
stuff yeah so um you know there there
it's an open world checklist which i
think is satisfying in the way that
checking things off a checklist is which
is fine I think a lot of open-world
games do that but you know the the nest
clearing is you know you go to an
infestation zone there's you know three
to six nests that the freaker's have
built and you have to burn them with a
Molotov to clear the infestation zone
that unlocks fast travel that area so
there's a couple benefits to it
it also clears some of the freaker's
from the area so you're like getting a
lot of benefits from it but pretty much
every infestation zone is like the same
it's really underscored by the fact that
Deacon says the same things at every
single one I smell a nest right here yes
gotta be right around here gotta be
close to a nest there's a point to doing
it but also it's just like there's no
like narrative you're not progressing
anything narrative lis not only are
these things repetitive they have like
tangible rewards but you don't really
see there's still zombies everywhere you
know like even though you burned up the
nest there's still human enemies even
though you clear their ambush camps and
they're all the same you're doing the
same things everyone he says the same
thing that everyone yes gotta be right
around here now moving on to probably
the elephant in the room as far as your
review goes is that one of the downsides
being the story and the overall
narrative the characters were
underwhelming to say the least right
yeah I mean this is this is what I
really mean when I talk about the game
dropping stuff and not following through
it is stays gone is is not it's not just
a story to be there like it's very story
focused and it takes the story very
seriously so you know you're Deacon
he's a former biker guy he and his best
boozer post Freaker outbreak they're
drifting they're just doing jobs for
different camps and deacons wife Sarah
was stabbed at the onset of the outbreak
and he puts her on a Nero helicopter and
he's like where are you going they say
this refugee camp and it turns out when
Boozer and Deacon got there it was
overrun and apparently everyone there
had died so it was like well Sarah's
dead so a lot of the first 20 hours of
the game is him like dealing with his
grief over Sarah two years later the
questline is literally dealing with my
past yeah yeah that's like the
description of the questline
so it's a lot of flashbacks with Sarah a
lot of the flashbacks are just like a
cutscene and then a little bit of
walking slowly behind Sarah and then
another cutscene and a little bit more
walking not really like super engaging
that way but also like their
relationship it's not that it doesn't
make sense but it it's not a convincing
relationship in the way that it should
be if I'm supposed to care so much about
Sarah's death you know like if I'm
supposed to care so much I need you to
do a little bit more convincing then
she's a nice girl scientist and he's a
bad guy biker and they love each other
anyway like okay Romeo and Juliet why do
I care I don't know why they love each
other like none of the none of the cut
scenes gives you a reason the one that's
been going around Twitter is the scene
of their wedding the flashback to their
wedding where Sarah literally says
promise to ride me as much as you ride
your bike cool so they like having sex
with each other that still doesn't tell
me why their love is the greatest thing
ever
so I just I find it flat I find Sarah in
these flashbacks kind of frustrating cuz
I'm like she's not like a full she's not
a three she's like a 2.5 dimensional
character and then she has a little bit
of personality but it's mostly just like
Deakins loves her butt and deacon just
thinks she's so great and Deakins always
messing with her because you know she's
really smart and he pretends not to know
things and then she explains them and
then she's like Oh
Deakin you got me again like it just not
it can get overly corny it's not a
convincing relationship and that just
doesn't work when the whole game is
about his grief about her right
it takes itself very seriously in that
regard and
then it throws but lying about riding a
bike at you there's a lot of there's a
lot of narrative narrative threads so
there's you get in Sarah that's a big
one yeah well there's Deakin and Boozer
early on the game loser gets attacked by
a doomsday cult called the rippers whose
story is so dumb that I'm not even don't
even worry about it
Boozer gets attacked by rippers they
singe a tattoo off of his arm for
reasons unbeknownst to Boozer and deacon
and then Boozer gets like third-degree
burns and then he like starts getting
blood poisoning and then tika needs to
go get antibiotics so deacons like in
the moment reason to be alive is to keep
Boozer alive he only cares about Sarah
and he doesn't really care about being
alive anymore but now I got to take care
of Boozer his best friend in the whole
world and you know Boozer those are fine
like he's a fine character he's not like
really interesting he really only exists
in service to Deacon just like Sarah
does then there's you know a camp a
little bit later on you got a sort of
love interest who you know deacons very
much committed to Sarah that's her whole
purpose is to prove how much he is
committed to Sarah and that brings me to
deacon is everybody in this game exists
to serve deacons wants deacons needs
deacons progression but Deacon doesn't
progress Deacon doesn't have a character
development arc Deacon doesn't learn
anything over the course of the game
so like the the newts example Deacon you
know he's been killing newts the whole
game or you've been killing newts I
found it uncomfortable Deacon realizes
like at you know our 45 but oh that used
to be someone's kid and then that
doesn't lead to any change you still
have to kill em you still have to kill
Newt yeah another example would be like
boozers health is only important because
it keeps Deacon wanting to go on Boozer
as a character you don't really learn
too much about him he apparently had a
wife you don't learn how she died or
when she died Boozer apparently shows no
grief about her death like so Boozer
only exists as something to keep Deacon
afloat in like there's a point where
Boozer tries to get through to deacon
about you know grief and like letting go
he like throws them on the ground it's
actually like a pretty good scene where
boos are like punches him in the face
and there's like where's your old lady
deacon
and deacons like she's dead she's dead
and I was like wow
a mission later Deacon sees an arrow
helicopter flying overhead and it was
like Sara might be alive I put her on an
arrow helicopter so like all of that
progression with Buser being a good
friend trying to get him to get over her
her apparent death grin thrown out
thrown out the window um and that just
keeps happening and there's more
examples that I can't even bring up
because they're spoilery but like Deacon
really learns nothing and the game is
not introspective at all about his
actions and you do a lot of not very
great things but they're all presented
as the right thing to do kill a ton of
people in this game but it's never like
Deacon never reflects back on that
they're brought up and they never seem
to have the impact yeah why would you
want to leave it's safe here I have to
work okay all of those narrative lines
just serve Deacon which could have been
somewhat fine not great writing but
somewhat fine if Deacon had been a
person who had learned at all from any
of those things you do a bunch of stuff
in this game you clear out those
infestation zones you clear out ambush
camps to make the road safer for the
innocent people who the ambush camps
apparently aren't you upgrade your bike
a bunch and you get this souped-up bike
to go where and and at the end it's like
well not all amounted to basically not a
whole lot the Nero stuff I think is the
the real highlight of the story and
unfortunately you know this this is the
thread I think that has the the longest
tail besides the Serra thread but it's
what carried me through the game in a
lot of ways because the Nero stuff is
not about deacon it's not about Sarah
it's not about Boozer it's about the
outbreak and I really like zombie stuff
and I like finding out what happened and
why and if there's a conspiracy like I
find that stuff interesting and like you
know in that way and this game actually
answers some some questions that zombie
fiction table often doesn't for example
like there's a series of missions where
you're spying on Nero people after he
sees that helicopter go overhead to get
more information and there are these in
stuff ales stealth missions and they're
kind of irritating at first this is a
quick aside about the mission structure
but their carrot a to get first then you
get an upgrade where you're more silent
at stealth and like they're really
problem after that I didn't I have a
huge problem with them because you're
overhearing these scientists these
government scientists talking about
freaker's and they're studying free
careers and like different types and
it's really interesting and like the one
example I put my review was there's one
where they're studying free curse cat
because Freaker poop is like a big thing
in this game the big deal from the nests
to this but they discovered from
analyzing it that the freaker's don't
just eat people and each other they also
eat plants and so they're not gonna
starve and you know that's the thing in
28 days later right like the zombies are
eventually going to starve and that's
like that's how you are free of the
zombie apocalypse in this game that's
not how you get free and I'm like ok
cool now we got to figure out a new way
to get rid of the zombies like I was
there for it I thought that those a cool
detail and there's areas where you can
find like Nero Intel and it's like these
recording like audio logs of
neuroscientists like doing research or
the moment a camp got overrun or you
know just to Nero soldiers like shooting
the [ __ ] and I liked that world-building
there's just I can't explain why but it
just doesn't follow through in the way
that I was gonna ask I was hoping for
and that's that's the one I was most
disappointed by really see that sounded
to me like
contact so we talked about what was in
the game your overall feeling something
that you did not talk about in your
review were the bugs and performance
issues with this game we asked you guys
if you have any questions for Kali and
one of them kind of corresponds to this
which is flynny asks are the problems
that are plaguing the game resolvable
that's a really good question and I
think it it leads into like my
philosophy on bugs and technical issues
in general I talked about this in my
anthem review also is that like a lot of
times technical issues can and will be
patched out and even during the course
of the review period I mean I had this
game for over a week like a week and a
half and you know problems were patched
out during that time and some of them
were irritating there were audio drops
where like the audio was just half the
audio would cut out and I have to save
my game and then started over that
happened a bunch of times and then it
never happened again for like another 30
hours it was bizarre and it was patched
out officially stuff like that like I
don't want to weigh heavily because
those things don't affect the the core
of what the game is
they are surface level flaws because
game development is hard and I think
it's good to acknowledge them and in
this case there was just so much to talk
about in this review that the bugs
almost seemed like that's not even
something I need to talk about because
there's so many issues I need to cover
but that said it's worth knowing that on
base ps4 I split my time pretty evenly
between a ps4 Pro at the office and my
personal ps4 which is a regular ps4 and
the game is really not optimized well
for a regular ps4 um it chugs a lot if
there's like rain and bunch of zombies
on the screen yeah if there's rain and a
horde you're basically the framerate
drops significantly um at the current
state current build it is ps4 Pro runs
better but it's still you know there you
do get framerate drops even on a pro so
there's like you know run-of-the-mill
bugs like that and then you know the
bigger stuff the the audio drops there
was a thing where rocks that you used to
distract enemies while you're in stealth
didn't work properly I never encountered
that they we were told explicitly that
they didn't work and I was like I think
they were crying
so stuff like that it doesn't run super
smoothly but there's nothing
game-breaking
and to answer the question about like do
the problems plaguing this game like can
they be resolved I think yeah bugs can
be resolved but like in order to make
this game better or to make it you know
not a 5 out of 10 as I gave it you'd
have to have a totally different
character and like the story would have
to be significantly
you can't retcon a 60-hour story that
meanders and goes through all these
things and abandons all these threads
and and well simply leads to no
character development like you can't
wreck on that the only thing that I
think could be improved by an addition
like a like a story DLC for example
would be the Nero storyline because I
was disappointed with the ending but it
wasn't totally like run into the ground
was there a cliffhanger at all I don't
want to say I really don't want to I do
think there's things that are worth not
spoiling in this game for people who are
interested in playing the game and who
maybe you know like don't find things
repetitive they are but if you don't
mind that that's totally very
prerogative so I do think it's not worth
spoiling but I will say that the Nero
storyline there's just like I had more
questions and there's things that could
be answered that wouldn't require any
liquor retconning sure other than that
like I think this story or this game has
a number of fundamental problems that
just like you can't you can't put a
bandaid on this sure core problems yeah
absolutely
yeah well that's gonna do it for this
video review of days gone thank you guys
so much for watching thank you Callie
for spending all the time playing the
game and covering it and that's can do
it
thank you guys again and stay tuned the
game spot for more video reviews
you
[Applause]
[Music]